pourquoi les sportifs devienne fou vous
êtes peut-être jamais posé la question
parce que vous aviez pas
particulièrement l'impression que les
sportifs devenait fou et en vrai vous
avez raison dans l'immense majorité des
cas les gens qui font du sport sont tout
à fait sain d'esprit
et d'ailleurs en vrai devenir fou ça
veut rien dire on en reparlera un de ces
jours mais est ce que vous connaissez
aaron hernandez
aaron hernandez c'est un joueur de foot
américain enfin c'était en 2010 malgré
une réputation de voyous aaron hernandez
fait ses débuts en nfl ultra prometteur
y signe un premier contrat de deux ans
plus tard sa fortune est fait et sa
carrière est lancée pas pour longtemps
puisque fin juin 2013 il est accusé du
meurtre d'un de ces aides aaron
hernandez est arrêté il a alors 23 ans
et deux ans plus tard il est reconnu
coupable et condamné à la prison à vie
mais l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là
puisqu'il est aussi accusé d'un double
homicide qui remonte à 2012 il est
acquitté en 2017 mais quelques jours
plus tard il est retrouvé pendu dans sa
cellule ses proches décident alors de
confier son cerveau au centre de
recherche sur lancé [ __ ] pâtit
traumatique chronique une maladie dont
on parle beaucoup chez les joueurs de
foot américain parmi les symptômes de ce
mal étrange causés par des chocs répétés
au niveau cérébral troubles du
comportement instabilité agressivité
impulsivité violence dépression suicide
c'est le docteur anne maquis la
directrice du centre spécialisé de
l'université de boston qui se charge
elle-même d'étudier le cerveau d'art aux
néerlandais elle dira par la suite que
c'est le cas le plus grave dans ses fans
au pâtis traumatique chronique qu'elle
ait jamais vu chez quelqu'un de si
jeunes en précisant que la maladie était
au stade 3 sur 4 est qu habituellement
les gens atteints à ce point sont morts
à l'âge de 46 ans alors qu'arnaud days
en à 27 l'experte peut pas en déduire
pour autant que la maladie est
responsable de ces troubles du
comportement et explique ces crimes elle
se contente de conclure que je cite les
individus avec des encéphalopathies
traumatique chronique de cette sévérité
ont des difficultés à contrôler leur
impulsivité et à gérer leur prise de
décision à calmer leur agressivité et
sont souvent instable émotionnellement
avec des comportements de rage le cada
rooney hernandez il est particulier vu
sa dimension judiciaire et la
personnalité du bonhomme mais il a
médiatisé syndrome en tout cas il l'a
fait connaître au grand public netflix a
même fait une série docu sur la sphère
alors vu comme ça ça ressemble à une
histoire incroyable une espèce de cas
exceptionnels mais
l'encéphalopathie traumatique chronique
elle n'a pas été découverte en 2017 et
aaron hernandez c'est pas le seul
sportif en avoir souffert loin de là
même en décembre 2020 une centaine
d'anciens joueurs de rugby
professionnels a porté plainte contre la
fédération internationale pour je cite
défaut de protection contre les risques
encourus après des commotions cérébrales
en 2012 donc avant même la faire à
renens d'eze ses 4500 joueur de foot
américain qui avait porté plainte contre
la nfl qu'ils accusaient de leur avoir
caché les effets des commotions
cérébrales à répétition bon à l'époque
la ligue leur a versé 7 165 millions de
dollars pour éviter le procès mais
derrière ces actions collectives il ya
une multitude de cas individuels
d'anciens sportifs avec des symptômes
physiques et psychologiques lourd et
autant d'histoires dramatique mais c'est
quoi exactement cette histoire
d'encéphalopathie traumatique chronique
une encéphalopathie traumatique
chronique littéralement c'est une
maladie du cerveau causée par des chocs
et qui est définitive alors ces chocs
c'est ce qu'on appelle des commotions
cérébrales c'est à dire le fait que le
cerveau soit ce quiz de façon vénère
comme on dit dans le jargon ça peut être
après un choc direct sur la tête même à
travers un casque mais ça peut aussi
arriver quand le choc intervient sur une
autre partie du corps mais que la tête
et quand même secoué vénère le jargon
toujours si vous vous souvenez bien on
en avait déjà parlé dans cette vidéo que
vous voyez là actuellement sur votre
écran je vous conseille d'aller à voir
vous comprendrez pourquoi déjà à la base
même une seule commotion c'est pas
anodin alors imaginez quand vous en
prenez plusieurs régulièrement pendant
des années alors avant de disséquer un
cerveau humain pour voir ce qui se passe
à l'intérieur mais on revenait on va pas
vraiment faire ça avant de passer à la
dissection donc on va faire un peu
d'histoire mes chers camarades bien
bonjour oh ouais non ouais non ça que ça
marche pas comme ça tu meures mais comme
avant romance te plaît non mais on croit
mais moi faudrait pas à temps non mais
j'aime bien comme ça en fait j'ai fait
un truc salut c'est mme banon a dit noël
les statuts réseau des petits gains
non mais c'est le sérum ah
oui alors dans l'espace qu'on fait comme
j'ai dit on va faire un peu d'histoire
et que ces moments car
elle a un prénom bon bref un peu
d'histoire donc dans la grèce antique
[Musique]
l'a mal pris manon je te demande pardon
je vous raconte dans la grèce antique
hippocrate avait déjà bien remarqué qu'à
voir le cerveau qui fait un role of
death c'était pas ouf alors il le disait
peut-être pas exactement en ces termes
je le cite de mémoire
dans ses aphorismes il écrivait je cite
il est mauvais qu'après un coup sur la
tête viennent la stupeur ou le délire à
hypo il avait le pire pour ces trucs là
un fort quand m donc vous voyez c'est
une notion qui datent pas d'hier mais on
va laisser hippocrate et on va faire un
saut dans le temps pour arriver au début
du 20e siècle à cette époque les
neurologues étudie les effets du souffle
des explosions sur le cerveau des
soldats de la première guerre mondiale
il remarque que ça a des conséquences à
la fois physique et psychologique et ils
appellent ça le choc
le choc de l'obus si vous voulez en
anglais et l'obuts site en français mais
c'est dans les années 20 qu'on va
commencer à s'intéresser aux sportifs un
médecin d'une onde harrison martland
décrit ce qu'il appelle le punch drunk
syndrome parce qu'à cette époque il
étudie problèmes sur des boxeurs chez
qui il observe des signes neurologiques
qui lui font penser que le cerveau a
souffert des mouvements bizarres des
difficultés à articuler voir des signes
de démence dans les années 30 différents
médecins continuent de se pencher sur le
cerveau abîmé des boxeurs pour décrire
l'ensemble des signes qui remarque il
utilise successivement des termes comme
encéphalite traumatique des pugilistes
dementia pugilistique à la folie du
boxeur et enfin encéphalopathie
traumatique chronique
il faudra attendre encore un peu pour
qu'on se rendre compte que ça ne touche
pas que les boxeurs
il faudra attendre 2002 pour qu'un
médecin légiste du nom de bennett au
malouf as parlé de l'encéphalopathie
traumatique chronique dans le milieu du
football américain après avoir autopsié
une ancienne star mike webster mort
brutalement après avoir souffert de
nombreux troubles du comportement et de
dépression une grande étude menée par le
docteur anne maquis sur plus de 200
cerveau d'anciens joueurs confirmera
tout ça par la suite et de nombreux
autres sports comme le rugby le hockey
sur glace et différents sports de combat
commenceront à se poser des questions
voire à faire évoluer leurs règles en ce
qui concerne les commotions cérébrales
on a même évoqué des troupes de georges
chez des footballeurs qui jouait
beaucoup de la tête malheureusement le
problème est loin d'être réglé puisque
en avril 2021 philippe adams un mec
joueur de foot américain a tué six
personnes avant de se donner la mort son
état mental c'était profondément
dégradée avant le drame et l'autopsié a
montré des lésions cérébrales
inhabituellement grave c'est ce que dit
le rapport et en décembre dernier
l'analyse du cerveau de vincent jackson
un autre joueur retrouvé mort dans une
chambre d'hôtel après plusieurs mois de
descente aux enfers a révélé la même
maladie ça c'est pour l'historique vous
voyez que ça date pas d'hier et que ça a
changé de nom pas mal de fois mais
qu'est ce qui se passe vraiment à
l'intérieur du cerveau de ces sportifs
l'encéphalopathie traumatique chronique
c'est le résultat d'une dégénérescence
progressive des cellules du cerveau un
peu comme la maladie d'alzheimer qui est
ce qu'on appelle une maladie
neurodégénérative qui touche aussi le
cerveau sauf que dans le cas qui nous
intéresse c'est les traumatismes répétés
qui causent des dégâts l'encéphalopathie
traumatique chronique donc elle évolue
par stade classés de 1 à 4 ça commence
avec des maux de tête et ça finit par
une démence pure et simple avec toute
une panoplie de signes physiques et
psychologiques qui dépendent des zones
du cerveau qui sont le plus touchés oui
vous savez dans le cerveau il ya
différentes zones responsable par
exemple du contrôle des mouvements de la
coordination de la mémoire de la prise
de décision du contrôle des émotions etc
les signes de la maladie donc ça peut
être des troubles de la coordination un
ralentissement des mouvements des
difficultés d'élocution c'est à dire du
mal à parler mais aussi des troubles du
comportement avec irritable et
impulsivité agressivité et violence même
des états dépressifs qui peuvent aller
jusqu'au suicide une tendance aux
addictions des troubles de la mémoire et
de la concentration
une confusion et donc à la fin la
démence mais bon concrètement comment
des chocs à la tête ça donne ce genre de
résultat on sait que quand il est trop
secouer ce soit à cause d'un choc à la
tête ou juste d'une décélération brutale
du corps comme dans un accident de la
route ou un bon gros stop au rugby ou au
foot américain le cerveau il aime pas ça
d'abord parce que même si baigne dans un
liquide qui amortit un peu les chocs il
peut se cogner contre les parois de
notre crâne mais aussi parce que l'ondé
de choc elle même elle peut se propager
de la surface jusque dans les structures
profondes et provoquer des lésions
d'ailleurs en plus des signes de
dégénérescence le docteur m'a qui a
retrouvé des traces d'hémorragie à
l'intérieur du cerveau d'arn hernandez
mais à vrai dire dans le cas de
l'encéphalopathie traumatique chronique
on connaît pas trop les mécanismes il ya
quand même quelque chose que le docteur
aux mâles ou avait remarqué dans son
autopsie grâce à un système de
coloration spécifiques il avait réussi à
mettre en évidence une accumulation de
protéines tau anormale dans le cerveau
de mike webster cette protéine tau en
temps normal elle a pour rôle d'assurer
la stabilité des neurones mais sous sa
forme modifiée elle est connue pour
envahir les cellules cérébrales et de
perturber leur bon fonctionnement en
donnant lieu à des maladies qu'on
appelle d'eto'o pâti comme la maladie
d'alzheimer d'autres maladies
neurodégénératives et certaines formes
atypiques de parkinson d'ailleurs il ya
des médecins qui n'ont pas hésité à
affirmer à l'époque que la maladie de
parkinson dont a souffert mohammed ali
de manière particulièrement précoce est
là c'était une forme d'encéphalopathie
traumatique chronique depuis la
découverte du docteur au mall où toutes
les études menées ont permis de mettre
en évidence le lien entre l'exposition
répétée aux commotions et des
accumulations cérébrale de protéines tau
anormale voilà maintenant vous savez
comment ça fonctionne mais
l'encéphalopathie traumatique chronique
c'est compliqué et tout le monde n'est
pas encore complètement d'accord son
sujet d'abord parce que certains
émettent des sur l'origine réelle des
troubles psys qu'on lui attribue ensuite
parce que le diagnostic est pas facile à
faire en général les examens comme les
irm ou les scanners ça montre rien de
suffisamment spécifique pour qu'on soit
sûr et puis comme vous avez vu les
signes ça ressemble à plein d'autres
maladies psychiatriques ou neurologiques
donc on est un peu obligé de procéder
par élimination en fait le seul moyen de
poser le diagnostic avec certitude c'est
l'autopsié parce qu'il faut aller
regarder à l'intérieur du cerveau pour
constater l'ampleur des dégâts et ça
c'est toujours compliqué à faire sur
quelqu'un de vivant et puis pour finir
parce que on comprend pas tout et
notamment pourquoi ça touche seulement
une petite partie des gens qui ont des
commotions à répétition même si on
évoque des prédispositions génétiques
chez ces gens là c'est pas clair mais en
tout cas on peut se mettre d'accord sur
le fait que c'est pas anodin de se
prendre des pet au casque de façon
répétée même des petits donc à chaque
fois que vous pouvez éviter de violentes
et votre cerveau ou celui des autres
évitez voit la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout manger du
caca de la bonne grosse merde j'adore
manger la mer du fait des bains de
bouche de merde des masques à la merde
des shampoings à la merde et je suis
julien ménielle toi tu es contente
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]